[Musique]
où
il
[Musique]
vous allez chanter ce soir à bordeaux et
que mettez vous à votre programme parti
de poutine et l'idée de puccini où je
chantais les airs de jeune expliqué de
les eaux du torrent dot manon manon
lescaut et visiteurs de tosca pour la
première partie
je lis que dans des salons mais la scène
finale de salon mais pour la deuxième
partie
salomé que je crois vous allez chanter
en entier bientôt oui on va la faire à
parier avec le nabaztag mois de
mai prochain quel personnage que vous
préférez et à trois personnages que je
préfère que je chanterai souvent ce sont
bien des normands et salomé et quel est
le plus difficile des trois je pense que
tous les trois sont difficiles et
difficile rôle que je me sentais seul
opéra de bellini et à deux époux ça
qu'on le chante pas moi non plus celui
que vous préférez
mais sait-on salomé salon m j'aime
beaucoup ce halo mais j'aime beaucoup ce
talent c'est d'abord c'est la première
fois donc que vous venez à bordeaux
vous connaissiez cette ville ou bien non
vous avez une autre piste vraiment la
première fois qu'on vient ici et c'est
la première fois que je suis dans le
théâtre
dedans on montre la salle montrer qu'on
peut tous les jours c'est fantastique
que si l'acoustique
non pas encore mais je devant nouvelle
tout le monde dit que j'étais bon alors
il faut croire que candice accola
romains ils se marchent comme ça ça veut
dire que c'est vrai et j'espère le
constater ce soir et en même temps
vraiment ici on a l'impression d'être
dans un vrai théâtre
[Musique]